you said
yes uh like you on the show we should
kick it sometime and then
then you said below it you said and by
kick it i mean like go on a date i find
you attractive or if like you made it
clear that it was a day yeah
demi lovato shooted their shot with
shit's creek star emily hampshire the
news came out when emily appeared on
demi's podcast 4d with demi lovato and
the 40 year old actress asked if she
could share how the two met
you dm'd me and you said i did i slid in
those dms what's wrong with being
confident
the confident singer said emily called
out their age gap saying she didn't
think they would find the same things
funny you also said think about sarah
paulson and holland taylor
no
then right after you're like i don't
mean you're the holland taylor that was
the funniest thing in the world because
i was
in that situation
of course demi came out as non-binary
earlier this year and added this
a
non-binary person can dream you know
what i mean and and and and they she i
at the time i was a she she was driven
she was dreaming big so i was like let's
let's let's see what let's see what can
i what's the worst that can happen and
then i made a really good friend you
know what i'm saying like you're you're
a dope friend and i'm like i'm happy
that we became me too i wish you weren't
29. love who you are i don't know why
i'm looking at the camera like you're
like me
um
love yourself and you're beautiful
that's it
after the flirty exchange both stars
revealed they are currently single emily
was once engaged to singer teddy geiger
while demi was previously engaged to
actor max eric
i have gotten to that point too where
i'm like but wait i really love my
grey's anatomy
marathons that i have by myself that
like i don't i don't know if someone who
i did is going to be interested in that
i went through some challenges and some
obstacles and i felt like at a period of
time i probably wasn't going to work
again but as i overcame those struggles
i it actually gave me more of a
i found my purpose through it all
[Music]